also ich kenne die debatte schon sehr
lange als ich wirtschaftsminister war
habe ich mir die arbeitsbedingungen dort
etwas genauer angeschaut es gibt doch
eine verabredung mit der
fleischindustrie was sie zu leisten zwar
ganz interessant zu gucken ob die
eigentlich wie damals getroffenen
verabredungen einheit und jetzt muss man
aufpassen über was man redet die
arbeitsbedingungen sind hart in der
fleischverarbeitung deswegen arbeiten
dort meistens übrigens keine deutschen
mehr weil sie diese arbeit nicht machen
wollen sondern werkvertrags arbeitnehmer
oft aus rumänien und bulgarien
das eigentliche problem sind oft die
wohn und lebensbedingungen die sich
daran anschließen und das hat mit
zweierlei maß zu tun erstens mit diesen
werks vertragsunternehmen die randow
holen unter welchen bedingungen das
passiert aber man muss auch ehrlich sein
das hat auch was damit zu tun dass die
dort beschäftigten in der regel jeden
euro sparen wollen und wie nach hause zu
schicken
das heißt das interesse daran eine gute
wohnung zu haben und nicht mit vier oder
sechs leuten auf einem zimmer zu wohnen
ist oft nicht sehr ausgeprägt weil es
eher um das haus und die familie zu
hause geht für das gearbeitet wird
trotzdem muss man sich um die wohnungs
bedingungen kümmern
ich glaube dass man allerdings jetzt mal
gucken muss ob das wirklich überall so
ist ich habe damals unternehmen
kennengelernt die sich nach den
damaligen skandalen tatsächlich
gekümmert haben wo sich dinge verändert
haben die obleute eingesetzt haben den
gewerkschaften gemeinsam gearbeitet
haben und es gibt offensichtlich
unternehmen die das nicht zu und ich
meine dieses unternehmen westfleisch das
muss schon eine besonderes robuste natur
haben wenn in einem teil des
unternehmens massiv fälle auftauchen und
dann nicht etwa die beschäftigung
gestoppt wird sondern die produktion
dort runter gefahren die gleichen
arbeitnehmer einfach nur ein paar
kilometer weiter die nächste fabrik
geschickt werden und das ist natürlich
ein abenteuerlicher umgang aber ich
glaube trotzdem muss man aufpassen muss
dass man sich die ganze industrie über
einen kamm schert und ich finde es ganz
gut wenn wir jetzt mal gucken würden
welche der getroffenen verabredungen die
die wohnungs bedingungen betrifft
übrigens durchaus auch die
als bedingungen vor allem die wohnungs
bedingungen sind eigentlich eingehalten
worden und welche nicht